hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga today I'd like to take a bit
of a step back into the title that was
my true gateway into anime as child
being Dragonball now an awful lot has
changed about this Universal of
multiverse I guess since my glory days
with it but the core fascination with
strength and power is certainly still
there so with that in mind we are going
to explore the five most powerful
characters that this property has to
offer and they're all pretty damn insane
far beyond any form of conventional
power measurement but we're here to do
our best with what we've got
don't worry I'm not going to go balls to
the wall of power scaling pointing out
why it does or doesn't work in an inlet
this is going to be a much more casual
exploration power so with that out of
the way let's begin welcome to the top
five most powerful characters in Dragon
Ball number five Zeno's attendants these
two figures are probably the most
mysterious characters will be
encountering here today who act
extremely seriously and in unison and
seemingly all times
in fact they very rarely speak at all
although they have briefly uttered the
words by chow which was translated to
later Gators in the Funimation dub which
is a very interesting contrast to their
rather stoic nature quite possibly
informed by the individual whom they
guard now very unfortunately we've not
really seen any demonstration of power
from this dynamic duo as of yet but
you'd think that to be charged with the
protection of the most important being
in the entirety of existence that they'd
have to be pretty damn strong yeah well
maybe maybe not because there's also
another argument that their purpose is
not to protect Senna at all but rather
to protect everyone else from the Omni
King because it is highly highly
unlikely that they would be able to do
anything that Zeno could not however
what we can more or less confirm is that
these attendants are more powerful than
the gods of destruction as both beerus
and champa were quite shocked and
intimidated by them so much as making a
move when they blocked Goku's approached
his inner and there are plenty of other
theories about them out there in the
world in regards to the possibility of
them being fallen angels whose universes
were destroyed but the key thing that
has me placing them in the number 5
position is the fact that the angels
we've seen so far in the series seem to
by and large be unconcerned with xenos
antics whereas these two attendants are
known to stress out quite a bit much in
the same manner as the gods of
destruction so without further
confirmation I certainly can't bring
myself to place anybody not already on
this list above them in terms of power
but at the same time given the knowledge
we have about the other four contenders
I certainly cannot place these
attendants any higher here today
number four wheeze I feel like we know
we're in for something special with we
spearing this far down the list because
he is already absolutely insane in every
way as an angelic attendant Lisa's
automatically on a higher plane of power
than even the gods of destruction and
has been known to casually brag about
being the fastest being in the universe
as such we see so powerful that he
actually trained beerus as well as goku
and vegeta these days although none of
the three have even come close to
scratching the sheer absurdity of power
within Lisa's possession and to
illustrate this we have some words from
mr. Toriyama himself we treated us to a
fake power scaling saying that if we
were to consider a Super Saiyan God as a
six and beerus universe sevens god of
destruction as a 10 then we sits at an
incredible 15 however it is not simply
raw power that lands waste in such a
commanding position but also his
extended and varied godlike abilities a
great example of which would be that we
see is able to rewind time by up to
three minutes with his temporal do-over
as well as craft interdimensional
portals warp through space and time and
even see events happening in those
particular spaces and times furthermore
we severe existence makes the primary
use of the titular Dragon Balls
redundant as he is capable of completely
resurrecting people and even strange
utility techniques like warping a baby
out of its mother's womb in order to
save her the time and trouble of
childbirth plus he can also access ultra
instinct and so so much more a much
better question would be to ask exactly
what we cannot do and in that regard all
I can really find on that comes from
beerus who claims that we cannot sing
finally something that he and i have in
common but regardless we see is a vessel
of truly inconceivable power and we've
still barely begun
number three vados
moving right along but not moving too
far we have Lisa's older sister and the
angelic attendant of universe 6 now in
comparison to Wiest not an awful lot is
known about vados however for a decent
comparison when the gods of universe 6
and 7 being champa and beerus
respectively got into a fight over a
puff-puff root both wheeze and vados
were able to put a stop to their battle
which had the potential to destroy you
know a mere entire universe simply by
providing them with a swift chop on the
neck and along with being the strongest
figure present in universe 6 this would
imply that at the very least Faro's and
we saw are about equal in terms of power
however this opinion does differ greatly
depending on who you ask Varro's herself
claimed someone modestly to be slightly
stronger than her younger brother
however this is
my great objection from Wiese who
casually points out that it has been a
millennium since the two of train
together which well that may be
difficult speak for modern day certainly
implies that a millennium ago vados was
indeed we so superior in fact at the
time of this recording the only thing we
have that even comes close to some sort
of official statement would be her
profile in an article in v-jump entitled
preparing for the tournament which goes
on to vaguely state that her true
strengths may indeed be greater than
that of Wiese whatever the case this
actually makes modestly strongest female
character examined so far in the entire
Dragon Ball series well without knowing
the quantity of the other female angelic
attendants anyway but I'm afraid that
that power alone does not even come
close to supremacy on this list number
two the great priest keeping things in
the family next up we have the father of
both Weesa and vados and in fact all of
the Angels would the great priest now
interestingly enough we do have some
official confirmation on where exactly
mr. priest ranks in the world having
been said by waste to be considered one
of the top five most powerful beings
within the entire multiverse which you
know makes an awful lot of sense
I mean think of everything that we see
and vados are capable of and then go on
to imagine the staggering power that was
capable of bringing them into existence
in fact we squat openly admits being
absolutely nothing compared to the
insanity of existence that is his father
although it should be stated that within
the Dragon Ball super manga which goes
into slightly more detail claiming that
the great priest is the strongest
warrior in the multiverse which is
semantically intriguing because of the
clarification of warrior which obviously
implies it in the specific art of combat
the great priest would be unmatched but
that does not necessarily make him the
pinnacle of power in the multiverse and
how good it really considering that he's
still in the number two spot here today
but regardless this being is no jerk
he can make gods of destruction quiver
in fear with a slight glare but even
with all of that in mind he's a pretty
chill dude and I mean why wouldn't you
be when practically nothing in the
multiverse is even a slight threat to
your continued existence in fact the
great priest even wears the kanji for
great on his belt so we do have a bit of
a humble brag happening there and that
sense of humility is exactly what he
needs in the presence of the most
overwhelming power in the multiverse but
before we get to exactly who that is I
feel like it's important to have some
honorable mentions in this case being
the rest of the angelic attendants we've
really only focused on two of them
during this video but the other ten
could very well be more powerful than we
Sandor vados it's just impossible to
know because we've literally seen
nothing of them although
do really know is that they are superior
to the gods of destruction and inferior
to the great priests plus these ten
angels that we haven't spoken about may
not even be the only other angels in
existence as apparently there were once
eighteen universes which leave six
angels unaccounted for
these angels may have been erased along
with their universes or perhaps they are
still out there somewhere laying dormant
regardless they do certainly deserve a
mention but for now let's have them fade
all the way back into obscurity as we
announce number one Zen oh now Dragon
Ball is a series that has explored the
idea of gods from it's very early stages
we've had mortals labeled themselves as
God's great overseers of the afterlife
an even greater presence in King Kai and
even higher levels of that with the
Supreme Kai all of whom were considered
quite godlike at some stage before the
literal gods of destruction were even
introduced well they're even they pale
in comparison to the Angels each of whom
are nothing compared to the great priest
who is even less than nothing in the
presence of sinner
this admittedly adorable character is
the epitome of power known as the Omni
King and this title is for very good
reason as he could wipe out any
universal even the entire multiverse in
the blink of an eye should he so wish it
well they're quite fascinatingly despite
possessing the ultimate in power cirno
is not at all a fighter and despite his
infinite abilities he can have
difficulty keeping up with the movements
of particularly strong martial artists
which was shown when he was completely
unable to observe the speed of dispo
instead requiring the slow-mo function
on his god pad to properly examine it
with that said there is certainly no way
that any fighter could so much as touch
sento in combat and T is said to be
completely unkillable which would
certainly make him our first proper
guard in the series as nobody prior to
him has truly been immune from the whole
death thing although yes there are a lot
of thoughts out there that have to do
with the possibility of Zeno being
killable like the entire idea that he
has bodyguards in the first place but
really if there is a force coming to
kill Senna then they're probably going
to be even less than useless anyway
however I suppose one possibility does
exist and that is that Zeno could kill
himself which may be a thing because
there's two xenos now due to a time
travel early stuff so I guess I should
point out that they take joint first
place on this list and it is unknown if
they could use their power to erase one
another not that that is ever likely to
happen because both Sano's get along
famously so for now we'll just have to
be satisfied with the idea that Zeno is
the pinnacle of everything that ever was
is and will be reigning as by far the
most powerful
character in all of Dragonball but that
pretty much does it for the top five
most powerful characters in Dragonball
if you enjoyed this video and the
content that's shown on produce in
general then please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps spot this channel
an incredible amount and if you'd like
to join the fun at any time then please
do head over to my discord server where
a wide array of shenanigan re takes
place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your own
strongest characters in Dragon Ball this
has been the new world review and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
of course I did forget wheezes most
powerful I set which is only revealed in
the den of witness that is xenoverse -
and it is of course the pooh staff and
with his supreme mastery of fecal matter
I highly doubt that even the great
sinner could stop him however since I've
already adjusted this much I'm not
really going to go back and change it
now so you win this time Center on a
technicality